Antisemitismus und Anstiftung zu Hass
die Frage ist was ist zu tun
zugeschaltet aus Frankfurt Main ist mir
jetzt Nancy Feser bundesinnenministerin
und zuständig für die innere Sicherheit
in Deutschland ich grüße Sie Frau Feser
hallo Frau benergy Frau fäer sie kennen
die Bilder den hamasterror der auf den
Straßen öffentlich gefeiert wird die
antisemitischen Parolen bei
Demonstrationen Häuser die mit David
Stern markiert werden und zu allem kommt
jetzt eine Polizei die mehr Klarheit
fordert z.B für das ein schreiten bei
Demonstrationen die Gewerkschaft der
Polizei ganz konkret wünscht sich von
ihnen dass sie die Länder zu bundesweit
einheitlichen Regeln bewegen werden sie
das tun also erstmal muss ich sagen mich
bewegen diese schrecklichen Bilder auch
sehr und es geht jetzt dieser Tage darum
dass der Rechtsstaat sehr stark
durchgreift gegen antisemitische Hetze
gerade bei den Demonstrationen gegen ein
schnelles Auflösen von Versammlung wenn
sie vorher verboten wurde oder wenn man
verbotene ähm Signale a auch sieht
insofern kann ich das nur unterstützen
das Versammlungsrecht ist mittlerweile
bei den Ländern ich werde in der
nächsten Innenministerkonferenz dafür
werben dass es diese rote Linie überall
einheitlich geben muss weil sonst die
Menschen auch Vertrauen in den
Rechtsstaat verlieren und das halte ich
dieser Tage für unheimlich wichtig ich
möchte dass Jüdinnen und Juden sich in
Deutschland sicher fühlen und dazu
gehört auch das antisemitische Hetze auf
unseren Straßen nicht geduldet wird auch
der Zentralrat der Juden sieht ja
Handlungsbedarf äh unter anderem beim
Thema Strafrecht zugleich haben die
Justizminister von Bund und Ländern erst
vorgestern
in einer Resolution praktisch gesagt wir
warten erstmal ab und prüfen ob es da
tatsächlich strafbarkeitslücken gibt
reicht ihnen
das ich komme gerade von der
Ratsversammlung des Zentralrates der
Juden und habe diese Frage auch dort
diskutiert ich finde wichtig dass dieser
Tage das Recht erstmal starke Anwendung
findet daran kann ich nur appellieren
ähm weil selbstverständlich ist es
wichtig dass A schnelle Strafen folgen
und B auch tatsächlich verurteilt wird
und man merkt dass man dort etwas falsch
gemacht hat dass es auch abschreckende
Wirkung für andere hat wenn man dafür
das Strafrecht ändern muss dann bin ich
dafür aber ich wäre jetzt erstmal dafür
dass geltendes Strafrecht auch wirklich
angewendet wird ich sehe viele
Einstellung das ist nicht gut
wir brauchen ein hartes Durchgreifen des
Rechtsstaates die Menschen müssen das
Sehen und die Täter müssen es vor allen
Ding spüren die Frage ist ja aber eben
wird denn das geltende Strafrecht
tatsächlich konsequent angewendet
schauen wir mal auf die Zahlen laut ZDF
Informationen registrierte das
Bundeskriminalamt seit dem 7.10 also
seit dem Terroranschlag der Hamas in
Israel mehr als 3000 Straftaten in
Deutschland im Zusammenhang mit dem
Hamas Terror die Justizminister sagen
Antisemitismus wird strafrechtlich schon
prioritär verfolgt aber es passiert doch
jetzt auf den ersten Augenschein erstmal
relativ wenig sehen Sie das da auch so
gelassen wie die
Justizminister nein ich sehe es nicht
gelassen ähm ich kenne die Zahlen
natürlich von meinem BKA ähm dass es äh
in Anführungszeichen nur 3000 Straftaten
sind ähm es ist eine große Zahl von
Straftaten insgesamt aber wir sehen
viele versammlungsgeschehen äh da
passiert noch viel mehr ähm und wir
haben ja nur die Straftaten die dann
auch tatsächlich verfolgt werden ich
glaube was wirklich wichtig ist dieser
Tage ist Beweissicherung bei den
Versammlungen ähm dass man auch die
Täter dann ermitteln kann und dass sehr
schnell eben verbotene sign äh Symbole
nicht mehr gezeigt werden wie Flaggen
wie Zeichen ich glaube dass wir da noch
mal drüber reden müssen dass alle auch
wissen was verboten ist ich habe ja mit
den Verboten gegenüber dem
Betätigungsverbot gegen Hamas und
samidun noch mal dafür gesorgt dass man
jetzt schneller auch eingreifen kann
härter vorgehen kann gerade bei
Versammlung und das ist etwas was in der
Öffentlichkeit stattfindet und deswegen
finde ich das dort so wichtig dass dort
das Strafrecht konsequent angewandt wird
und da sehe ich noch Luft nach oben der
Sicherheitsexperte peter Neumann sag
sagt dass vor dem Hintergrund des Israel
Krieg des Krieges gegen die Hamas jetzt
gerade die Terrorgefahr deutlich wächst
und dass in Europa Einzeltäter sehr bald
versuchen werden auch in Europa
Terroranschläge auszuüben vor dem
Hintergrund
ähm stellt ihre Ankündigung jetzt im
Asylrecht Asylverfahren durch weniger
Überprüfung von Asylbewerbern zu
beschleunigenen starken Kontrast da
halten sie auch vor dem Hintergrund der
geschilderten Terrorgefahr daran
fest also bei den Beschleunigung der
sülverfahren geht es ja darum dass mit
den Ländern und Kommunen vereinbart
wurde wie kann man unnötiges
Verfahrensrecht rausnehmen die
Sicherheitsüberprüfung daran wird nicht
gespart wir werden natürlich nach wie
vor die Sicherheitsüberprüfung machen
daran geht kein Weg vorbei und da gebe
ich auch kein pondant das wird weiterhin
durchgeführt das heißt was lassen sie
dann weg
stattdessen also manchmal gab es noch
eine zusätzliche Befragung
beispielsweise ein Ausländerbehörde das
würde künftig wegfallen ich glaube das
ist verzichtbar wie gesagt das kommt von
den Kommunen und den Ländern
aber bei den Sicherheitsüberprüfungen
oder den Abfragen im schengenystem
werden wir nicht nachlassen und auch
selbstverständlich gibt es eine
vollständige
Identifizierung derjenigen die zu uns
kommen sagt die bundesinnenministerin
Frau fäer herzlichen Dank für das
Gespräch ich danke Ihnen Frau benergi